after a long tense wait the final season
of Game of Thrones finally premiered on
April 14 2019 with the first episode
coming in at just under an hour
despite being packed full of revelations
reunions and more the return of Jon Snow
Daenerys Targaryen the three living
Lannisters and the metric ton more of
the show's characters brought a few
answers and even more questions with
them questions like did you catch when
Mack from It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia showed up he has everything
else of importance that happened in a
game of Thrones season premiere and
everything we still want to know for the
remaining episodes of the series
the trailers leading up to the premiere
offered plenty of shots of Daenerys
arriving at Winterfell and audiences
didn't have to wait long
in the very first shot of the season
premiere a Winterfell boy climbed a tree
to see Daenerys his army arrived with
the mother of dragons and her right-hand
man Jon Snow flanked by dragons and
sullied and Dothraki as they arrived at
the stronghold of the north
appropriately for the chilly north the
welcome is less than warm considering
northerners are instinctively
distrustful of any foreigners especially
a new queen from the far south and two
enormous dragons it isn't just a
townspeople who don't trust Daenerys
Sansa John sister immediately dislikes
the Dragon Queen who she considers at
once naive and arrogant for trusting
Cersei to serve as an allied to the
north
whatever sanz's attitude might be it's
clear that Daenerys is assimilation into
the northern way of life won't be simple
and will likely be a struggle for the
rest of the season Cersei Lannister is
always one of the toughest characters to
read and in their premiere she's just as
inscrutable as ever
still astride the Iron Throne she seems
completely unperturbed by the news that
the White Walkers have breached the wall
especially considering that the golden
company an army of mercenaries and the
Circe's control has just arrived at
King's Landing
thanks to her unlikely fiance Joran
Greyjoy after he delivers her new army
the two finally consummate their
relationship which leads to probably one
of the least sexy post romance lines
were here all week
as you might expect the icy Queen looks
pretty uncomfortable sipping a glass of
wine as he leaves her room
last season audiences heard Cersei told
Jamie she was pregnant with Jamie's baby
who changed it father yeah meanwhile
Tyrion found out about his new niece or
nephew a couple episodes later the
unborn child still seems to be a secret
so after she drove Jaime to abandon her
at the end of season seven Cersei may
manipulate your run into being the next
man to him wittingly claimed one of
Jaime and Cersei skids as his own mother
Cersei has creeped out by a new
boyfriend or she's planning to pull a
Maury until you're on he's the father
we'll just have to wait for a future
episode to find out the most brutal
reveal regarding Cersei ultimately comes
from Qyburn per resident mad scientist
who shows up drawing one of fronds
routine brothel visits to casually tell
him that Cersei would like both of her
brothers dead and the one to do it would
be rewarded beyond his wildest dreams
Cersei obviously has a plan in place but
how it will unfold is still anyone's
guess
ever since viewers found out the truth
about Jon's parents that he was actually
born to illegally married Lyanna stark
and rhaegar targaryen making him an
undisputed prince fans have been waiting
for Jon to find out sir and this episode
got right to the point
aside from plenty of pointed comments
about who John is there's one huge
moment in this episode hinting at Jon's
true heritage followed by the big reveal
that finally puts one of the show's
biggest revelations in front of the
person it'll affect the most Jon still
blissfully ignorant to the fact that
he's been sleeping with his aunt it's
having a lovely day date with his new
girlfriend until she suggests that they
write her two remaining dragons with
Daenerys riding drogue on the dragon she
always takes into battle Jon is left
with regal who was actually named for
his father Daenerys has brother Rhaegar
in the moment it feels especially
significant that Regan allows Jon to
mount without protest however at the end
of the episode the show does away with
all the pretense that it will keep this
secret
letting Sam sell Jon the entire truth
about who he is much to Jon shark and
naturally all happens right in front of
Ned Stark statue in the crypt reunions
between favorite characters ranked among
the most important and anticipated
moments in the season and
premier certainly didn't disappoint even
though some of them weren't particularly
happy Eyre and John's reunion at the
godswood in Winterfell was certainly one
of the episodes most emotional moments
even giving the two a minute to compare
their swords meanwhile another brother
Theon showed up in the eleventh hour to
rescue his sister Yara who eventually
showed her gratitude in the most greyjoy
way possible so Jorah Mormont's also got
a chance to thank some tally who once
cured him of greyscale though their
reunion took a pretty sour term when
Stern arias let Sam know what she did to
the rest of his family last season the
reunion between Sansa and Tyrion was
almost as tense since Sansa doesn't
believe in him or his plans anymore
another tense reunion took place between
Jon and Sam especially since hysterical
Sam holds the key to Jon's parentage and
is fresh off the discovery that he's now
the only tar demon left however the most
fraught was definitely between Jamie
Lannister and bran stark whence a former
arrives at Winterfell
considering that Jamie last saw bran
when he pushed him out of a window and
tried to kill him in the very first
episode audiences haven't seen tormund
Giantsbane everyone's favorite redheaded
wildling since he was spotted at East
watch last season as the wall melted
around him so fans were likely thrilled
to see both torment and beric Dondarrion
alive but not particularly well at
another northern Castle trying to figure
out how many dead they had to deal with
and whether or not the army was close by
ultimately they find the body of young
Ned umber the tiny leader of the house
amber pinned to the wall and surrounded
by dismembered limbs and a spiral
pattern which barrack notes as a message
from the night king spiral patterns
shouldn't surprise any loyalty of
Thrones viewers especially not where
White Walkers are concerned in the very
first episode the walkers arranged the
limbs of their victims in a circular
pattern somewhat reminiscent of the one
that includes poor dead Ned they can
also be seen using dead horses to draw
the spiral sign in season 3 when Jon and
the wildlings go to the fist of the
first men
the artists
so what does the spiral mean well it's
pretty simple this is a knight Kings way
of telling the armies of Westeros
although a averts the White Walkers are
coming and probably in the very next
episode check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more loop of
videos about Game of Thrones are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and to the Bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]